hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt ein leckeres türkisches
gericht ich werde nämlich cache machen
und zwar gibt es ja ganz viele
verschiedene arten von kebab und ich
denke viele verwechseln mit kleber hier
bezeichnet eigentlich so ein
fleischgericht also egal ob es jetzt auf
dem grill gemacht wurde oder zum
beispiel in einem topf oder in einem
tontopf mit etwas soße das ist alles
klappt und döner kebab ist dann
praktisch nur dieser kebab also das
fleisch am spieß was dann eben später zu
dünger verarbeitet wird und heute möchte
ich eine variante machen aus dem ofen
und zwar eigentlich wird es in so einem
tontopf gemacht ich habe jetzt aber
keinen tontopf deswegen nehme ich hier
so eine stone wer also einen stein gefäß
und werde sich gleich vorbereitet und
das heutige gericht mache ich mir etwas
auberginen und tomaten und zwiebeln
aber ich zeigen hier bei gosee zutaten
sprache vier esslöffel und da habe ich
jetzt ein sonnenblumenöl 2 zwiebeln drei
tomaten ich brauche zwei esslöffel
tomatenmark dann auberginen ich habe
jetzt hier eine große und mittelgroße
also zwei auberginen dann brauche ich
natürlich auch fleisch ist jetzt etwas
mehr aber ich brauche da von nur 500
gramm und es ist setzen flammt fleisch
aber wir können auch ein kalbsfleisch
nehmen dann habe ich hier lorbeerblätter
etwas chili und kreuzkümmel und
natürlich salz und pfeffer und ich
bereite jetzt zuerst mal und zwar
nämlich die aubergine und schneidet
sitzt da oben alles grün weg und die
werde ich jetzt erstmal in salzwasser
einlegen damit einfach diese
bitterstoffe weg gehen und dafür stehe
ich jetzt auch mal kurz
dann halb erichsen
jetzt schneidet sie in kleine würfel und
zwar so etwa ein zentimeter würfel und
ich schädel jetzt übrigens nicht ganz
als er sich gerade selber aufgefallen
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht wieso aber
in türkischen gerichten ist es wirklich
oft so dass die verschiedenen einfach
nur so grob geschält werden
ich glaube dass dienst ein bisschen der
dekoration aber naja ich hab von meiner
mama übernommen hier können sie gern
auch ganz schön oder sie schauen auch
ganz dran da sind stört absoluten hat
es gebe ich die in eine glasschale
die zweite verschieben lassen jetzt weg
diese jetzt in bisher groß und jetzt
gebe ich hier so ein bisschen salz
drüber das zieht wie gesagt die
bitterstoffe weg übrigens habe ich mir
doch eine erklärung überlegt warum man
die aubergine vielleicht noch zur hälfte
schält wenn man nämlich die auberginen
also im ganzen weiter verarbeiten würde
und die so in salzwasser legt kommt das
salzlager natürlich die schale flex
schneider steht man deswegen nur die
hälfte
man kann das als immer noch durch
geschafft oder die bitterstoffe eben
raus ziehen jetzt hier mit etwas wasser
offen
und das lasse ich jetzt einfach so ein
bisschen stehen
dann steige ich jetzt schon mal das
gemüse klein g zwiebeln schneidet in
kleine würfel
und die tomaten werden jetzt geschält
weil die schale später in der soße etwas
stören würde
weil sie eben hart bleibt
und die tomaten schneide ich jetzt auch
noch in würfel
mit schneide ich noch ein halbes kilo
von dieser lammkeule knallen
und zwar auch in kleine würfel und die
haben dann so ungefähr 1 zentimeter
größe
jetzt habe ich die pfanne bereits
erhitzt und gebt da das öl hinein
man muss jetzt endlich das fleisch ganz
anbraten
und wenn es dann rundherum angebraten
ist gebe ich noch die zwiebelwürfel mit
dazu
und sie werden jetzt so auch etwa drei
minuten noch mit gebraten
jetzt ist die flüssigkeit verdunstet und
ich kann es das tomatenmark dazugeben
also wie gesagt zwei esslöffel man kurz
verrühren
dann auch direkt ein glas heißes wasser
und jetzt schalte ich den herd aus und
kann bereits die maschinen abschließen
die auberginen waschen jetzt auch kurz
ab weil jährige salzen waren
jetzt kann ich auch direkt die
auberginen in den topf geben
den habe ich vorher ein bisschen
gerettet
dann gebe ich zum fleisch von butler
bitten
das kann jetzt auch einfach darauf legen
weil das fleisch darüber gegossen
dann die tomaten noch drüber
und jetzt gebe ich dann noch einen
halben teelöffel kreuzkümmel dazu hätten
jetzt auch mit ins fleisch geben können
habe ich ganz ehrlich zu vergessen aber
es wird dir eva möchte später einfach
schön verteilen dann einen halben
teelöffel chili
das pfeffer und noch etwas salz wobei
ich später noch nach salz werde jetzt
schließlich den deckel und dann kommt es
so in den vorgeheizten backofen bei
ungefähr 170 grad für etwa 40 minuten
und ich werde auf jeden fall nach 40
minuten schon mal probieren ob das
fleisch schön weich ist und ob das
gemüse schön durch ist und dann zeige
ich euch gerechtes ergebnis
das kammergericht ist fertig tasci bot
tasci sieht es jetzt aus
ich muss das jetzt natürlich erst mal
durchführen denn die gewürze liegen da
es obendrauf
schlecker also die aromen und verbinden
sich halt richtig gut in so einem stein
da gibt's natürlich verschiedene
überreaktion ja und ich gebe es hier
noch bisschen thymian mit rein
das passt finde ich auch ganz gut dazu
wollte nicht so richtig an urlaub war
richtig das lorbeerblatt könnt ihr raus
nehmen sobald jetzt findet weil es kann
ja nicht mit essen jetzt einmal
abschmecken
irgendeiner wird das lorbeerblatt finden
auch genug salz pfeffer drin ist hier
irgend einer findet lauert immer aber
auf jeden fall muss bei mir noch etwas
salz und pfeffer mit rein
so morales selbst probieren ich hab hier
einfach so ein langkornreis mit dazu
gemacht ein türkischer reis wird
natürlich am besten passen aber wir
mögen auch ganz gern zum einfachen reis
den ganzen tag nicht gegessen
ich hoffe ihr habt jetzt genug salz rein
für dich ich glaube ich hab so hungrig
wieder autoreifen essen das schmeckt dir
jetzt schon noch ein bisschen deko reden
ich glaube die meisten kenntnisse man
wirklich viel gearbeitet hat und wenn
man richtig viel gearbeitet und dann
essen geht dann schickt euch alles
möglich das darfst du gerne probieren
also ich mag die variante auch mit
kartoffeln champignons und filmen ja die
variante finde ich auch super
ich mag auberginen ganz gerne wenn ich
gespannt ob du das auch magst und falls
ihr übrigens noch andere variationen
sehen wollt oder auch selber welche
kennt könnt ihr mit gerne in die
kommentare schreiben und dann mach ich
dir gerne auch nach wenn ihr das sehen
möchtet super ist viel nur soll's ok
dann darf schon rufen nach salz habe ich
mir fast gedacht aber das kann ja auch
jeder am tisch machen oder ihr schmeckt
einfach nochmal ab und ich finde dass es
ein super tolles rezept was man auch gut
vorbereiten kann
denn man bereit ist kurz in der pfanne
vor und dann gibt man es einfach in den
backofen zum weiter garen
wie gesagt falls ihre variationen kennt
dann schreibt mir wir werden auf jeden
fall bestimmt auch mal döner kebab
machen oder moral wurde danach gefragt
ich werde auf jeden fall irgendwann mal
machen und ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz
viel spaß beim nachkochen und wir sehen
uns das nächste mal wieder bis bald